white's king will run the other
direction and
and uh the
the big thing about this position is
wesley cannot wait with his rook either
because as soon as he retreats that rook
while the white ball will step forward
one square and now you can just see
magnus is in his element he knows
exactly what he needs to do and that is
he's trying to create some a path
into the
into the blah blah blah i'm getting too
excited about this
is he's trying to find a way for his
king to come in to the into the right
side of the board yeah so right now
those two black pawns they're stopping
the white king advancing even further so
i'm expecting c magnus actually not
recapture with his king here i'm
expecting him to willingly take a set of
doubled pawns i'm expecting him to play
pawn takes pawn and then to use that
pawn next move to just break up black's
pawn formation on that right flank and
i'm i think that's pretty much game over
i'm surprised the computer the
evaluation bar isn't the whole way over
to white side because
we've studied this type of thing many
times this is kind of endgame 101